und dann verleihen wir dass es
eigentlich eine selbstverständlichkeit
noch einen vollpfosten an den
hitzesommer 2018 und zwar in der
komplett eingeklemmten
sonnenschutzfaktor 50 edition hab den ja
wirklich eingekriegt segler
denn ganz deutschland echte monatelang
unter der gnadenlosen sonne seit ende
märz wahnsinn
die 20 wärmsten jahre seit beginn der
wetteraufzeichnungen lagen übrigens in
den vergangenen 22 jahren man möchte
fast von einem trend sprechen jedoch
egal denkt da vielleicht der ein oder
andere ich mag's war aber dann haben sie
das hier wahrscheinlich nicht
mitbekommen da hitze geteilt der
wichtige rohstoff gerste schlecht geht
es so weiter mit dem thema könnte sich
der bierpreis weltweit im schnitt etwa
verdoppeln der bierpreis ab jetzt ist
der klimawandel persönlich freunde
immerhin wird kölsch nicht teurer denn
das ist ja bekanntlich kein bier mehr
treiben können das studio kommt das
immer super
ja dürre und dauer hitze in deutschland
überschwemmungen in frankreich spanien
und italien laut wissenschaftlern wohl
eine folge der erderwärmung
beziehungsweise des schwächeren
jetstreams hoch und tiefdruckgebiete
hängen jetzt viel länger an bestimmten
stellen fest mit schlimmen folgen auch
im fernsehen diesen sommer wirklich nur
völlig sinnlose hitze berichte des
nachts wird dann in der unterhose
geschlafen hatte angekündigt die lassen
noch interaktion hat gesagt junge du
gehst mal bei der hitze in die sauna
würde ich sonst eigentlich nicht machen
und guckt da doch mal wie ist es bei den
temperaturen in der sonne und wer kommt
da überhaupt für tannenbaum züchter wie
august klein rechts sich hingegen der
ungewöhnlich trockene sommer ich sehe
kein neuland so hier müsste einen stehen
aber das steht ja keine
tja unsichtbare weihnachtsbäume vielen
dank hitzesommer dankeschön jetzt aber
die schlechte nachricht freunde selbst
wenn alle staaten ihre 2015 stolz
verkündeten klimaziele erreichen würden
was sie nicht tun weil sie nichts dafür
tun wird bis zur jahrhundertwende 3,2
grad wärmer absolute katastrophe sind
nicht übertrieben und auch deutschland
hat immer noch einen viel zu hohen
kohleanteil in der stromversorgung
umweltministerin svenja schulze musste
gerade mit leeren händen zur
klimakonferenz ins polnische kattowitz
ist so traurig ja wir haben zwar eine
sogenannte kohle kommission aber die
streitet nur noch auch die verkehrswende
klappt gar nicht unter anderem weil
viele deutsche immer noch fette suvs
fahren was zu problemen führt die sie
sich gar nicht vorstellen können und da
gibt es tolle angebote aber so in der
größenordnung bei 160000 euro bis ende
das heißt während mögliche stop
automobil haben möchte in dem segment
der kann bislang nur maximal 160 tausend
euro ausgeben
genau dieses problem lösen wir gott sei
dank
gottseidank damen und herren bentley
sowie für über 160000 euro oder wie
friedrich merz sagen würde
gehobene mittelklasse waren
die ernüchternde deutsche klimabilanz
was heißt das jetzt für den deutschen
privathaushalt wir schalten wir live
nach berlin
dort feiert dörte hausten geschiedene
knielingen dingeldey von den kreuzberger
grünen komplett co2 freie weihnachten
frau geschrieben allen dingen wie
funktioniert das denn
smiljanic ist totale kacke echt jetzt
gebt mir die ganze zeit wieder letzter
kein auto keine flugreisen wir machen
urlaub mit dem fahrrad in brandenburg an
sich hungermann berlin
da kann man sich auch gleich erschießen
es muss ja ich lese zwischen den zeilen
eine gewisse verbitterung sagt bloß ich
meine katze so jung wie nie
ich hab mir seit acht jahren immer die
haare waschen ich trau mich ja schon
immer die mütze abzunehmen weil ich
nicht wissen will was darunter lebt in
kanada hänni er hat sich 2017 die hüfte
gebrochen und würde ja mal zum arzt aber
exakt in die ganze zeit ne henning sorry
solange es keine elektrischen
krankenwagen gibt und die bald ist
weihnachten und wir haben nicht mal
einen baum
wir legen die ganze palette einfach
immer oh no kurz gesagt reiß hier hier
klimatechnisch den arsch auf und dann
kommt die meldung die welt hat einen
neuen co2 rekord aufgestellt
nach vielen dank für jahr ist ich bin
raus man raus ich laufe jetzt
australischen rotweinen das am weitesten
geflogen so sieht's aus auch deutschland
ja verfehlt seine ziele mit karacho
haben sie mal unserer sogenannten
kenntnissen zu iran das bei uns der co2
ausstoß seit jahren ja mehr oder weniger
stagniert ganz leicht sinkt wie
verkaufen sie das den anderen ja wir
haben uns wirklich gute ziele gesetzt
aber wir haben zu wenig getan um die
ziele zu erreichen
standbein ihr abizeugnis svenja hatte
sich lutetia sitzt aber leider habe ich
getan um sie zu erreichen
17 staaten weltweit haben hier ein
klimaziele erreicht da muss man seinen
kindern und enkeln oma ganz ehrlich
sagen die leute wir hätten euch ja einen
funktionierenden planeten hinterlassen
aber wir hatten leider kein bock das
bisschen hart vielleicht genau so muss
man es machen ja das sage ich jetzt auf
meinen sohn den syrern gandalf höheren
gang rauf mit der toten karte zu spielen
nikolaus geschenk passt mal auf kleiner
mann
die mama wollte eigentlich die ehre
retten aber das lasse ich jetzt doch
wenn man ist ich bin im yoga retreat of
sri lanka den flieger hebt gleich und
für die zeit nach dem klimawandel habe
ich noch ein geschenk für dich
schwimmflügel schützling dort
ausgeschieden
[Applaus]
[Musik]